اصابه عسكريين سوريين في هجوم الاسرائيلي
استهدف محيط العاصمه السوريه دمشق
في السودان الحريه والتغيير تحسم موقفها
اليوم من هيكله السلطه والجيش يؤكد
التزامه بالعمليه السياسيه
او يطالبون بوقف تطوير انظمه الذكاء
الاصطناعي مؤقتا بسبب خطرها على المجتمع
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا الى نشره لاهم الانباء
من العربيه يقدمها لكم ابراهيم بدر اصيب
عسكريان سوريان بجروح جراء قصف جويا
اسرائيلي طال مواقع في محيط دمشق وكانت
وسائل الاعلام سوريه تحدثت عن سماع دوي
انفجارات اثر الهجوم الذي يندرج ضمن سلسله
غارات تشنها اسرائيل في سوريا مستهدفه
قوات حكوميه او ميليشيات مدعومه من ايران
ومقاتلي حزب الله اللبناني
افادت وسائل اعلام اسرائيليه بان الرئيس
الامريكي جو بايدن وجه رساله قاسيه لرئيس
الوزراء الاسرائيلي بنيامين التنياهو بعد
اقالته لوزير الدفاع وانجلانت
واوضحت المصادر الاسرائيليه ان بايدن طلب
نتنياهو بالتراجع فورا عن تعديلات القضائي
في رساله نقلها السفير الامريكي التي كانت
شخصيه وسريه وهدد الرئيس الامريكي رئيس
وزراء اسرائيل بالاستبعاد من قمه
الديمقراطيه اذا لم يوقف تعديلات القضاء
في السياق ذاتها اكد مسؤول اسرائيلي ان
نتنياهو يريد تجنب ازمه مع بايدن ويريد
وضع ازمه القضاء خلفه
بالتلميح والتصريح ازمه التعديلات
القضائيه تخرج الى العلى الخلافات بين
الحليفين القويين من واشنطن الى تل ابيب
والعكس ايضا يرفض الرئيس الامريكي دعوه
رئيس الوزراء الاسرائيلي الى البيت الابيض
في المستقبل القريب فبايدن قلق للغايه يرى
ان الاستمرار في هذا الطريق ليس ممكنا في
اسرائيل
لا يتاخر يرد وبطريقه غير مسبوقه رد حمل
اشارات واضحه الى الولايات المتحده
اسرائيل لا تخضع لضغوط من الخارج بما في
ذلك من افضل الاصدقاء
وللاصدقاء تحديدا يقول وزير الامن القومي
الاسرائيلي اعتمار بن غفير ان اسرائيل
ليست نجمه على العلم الامريكي متوقعا ان
يفهم بايدن هذه النقطه فهل فهمها بايدن
القناه الثانيه عشره الاسرائيليه نقلت عن
مسؤول امريكي قوله ان نتنياهو اخطا فهم
الرد الامريكي على انقلابه القانوني
المسؤول الامريكي قال ايضا ان نتنياهو
اساء التقدير بتصريحاته حول بايدل خرجت
التصريحات اذن اصدائها سمعت في اسرائيل
واشنطن لكنه صدن يعكس غضبا واحباطا
امريكيين من نتنياهو وحكومته كما تقول
صحيفه يدعو تحرنوت نقلا عن مسؤول اسرائيلي
كبير
ورغم تحذيرات نتنياهو لاعضاء ائتلافه من
الحديث عن الازمه مع واشنطن الى انا وزيره
التعليم الاسرائيلي يوافقيش حذر الولايات
المتحده من التدخل في الشؤون الداخليه
الاسرائيليه وزير التعليم اضافه بان النجم
الرئيس الوزراء
غير متورط في اي شيء يتعلق بخطه تغيير
النظام القضائي
في رد على سؤال العربيه قال متحدث باسم
مجلس الامن القومي الامريكي جون كيرربي ان
تصريحات رئيس الوزراء الاسرائيلي نتنياهو
كان بها نقاط ايجابيه مشددا على ان بايدن
ونتنياهو يتمتعان بصداقه قويه تمتد
لاربعين عاما
اذا نظرنا الى تصريح نتنياهو هناك الكثير
من الايجابيات فيه تحدث عن البحث عن حل
الوسط وعن العمل على بناء توافق فيما
يتعلق بهذه الاصلاحات القضائيه المحتمله
وتحدث ايضا عن مدى ثباته في اهميه العلاقه
بين الولايات المتحده واسرائيل وعن
احترامه الكبير للرئيس بايدن وهذا احترام
يشاركه فيه الرئيس بايدن ايضا نتنياهو
وبايدن يعرفان بعضهما منذ اربعين عاما
والشيء الرائع في الاصدقاء وانا متاكد من
ان لدينا اصدقاء جميعا فنحن لا نوافق
دائما على كل ما يفعله او يقوله اصدقائنا
والشيء رائع في الصداقه العميقه هو اننا
يمكن ان نكون صريحين مع بعضنا
في السودان اكد الجيش التزامه التام
بالعمليه السياسيه الجاريه مشيرا الى انه
ينتظر عمل لجان الفنيه التي تعمل على
اكمال التفاصيل المتعلقه بعمليه الدمج
والتحديث من جهته يعقد المجلس المركزي
لقوه الحريه والتغيير في السودان اليوم
اجتماعا لاجازه الاتفاق السياسي النهائي
المنتظر توقيعه في الاول من ابريل المقبل
وحسب موقفه حيال هيكله السلطه السياديه في
الحكومه المدنيه
في اخر محطاتها العمليه السياسيه تتعثر
انها ورشه الاصلاح الامني والعسكري التي
عقدت لاربعه ايام متتاليه قدمت فيها اوراق
تناقش التفاصيل الفنيه لهذه العمليه التي
يرى البعض انها معقده
التعقيد الذي تجلت صورته هنا بالقاع التي
احتضنت ختاما غاب عنه ممثل الجيش والشرطه
وجهاز المخابرات العامه وحضر ممثل قوات
الدعم السريع حاجات ان الامور كانت تزيد
بطريقه ممتازه وصبيحه هذا اليوم كان يفترض
نجلوس ايضا حتى نناقش
المناجيز التوصيات التي تقدم بها الاخوه
العسكريون وفوجئنا انه المساله تاجلت لهذا
النساء
خرجني بما خرجنا به قبل قليل
ورغم المخاض العسير لهذه العمليه والمخاطر
التي تتهددها يظل الامل قائما لانهاء حاله
الاحباط التي سيطرت على الكثيرين ممن
حضروا هذه الجلسه في السبب يخلي الجيش ما
يكون موجود في الجلسه الختاميه لانه انا
ما بعرف الحصل شنو في اللحظات الاخيره لكن
ده ما بيخليني انه انا اكون عندي يعني
معكم متفائله بانه حيحصل لقدام خير وانه
الاتفاق الاطاري حيمشي لمراميه
يصل للهدف بتاعه النهائي
القوه الموقعه على الاتفاق الايطالي ترى
ان اللجان الفنيه ستواصل عملها لاستكمال
وصياغه التوصيات النهائيه التي تشكل عقبه
تسعى الاطراف لتجاوزها هذا وسط واسط
اللجان المتخصصه منا العسكريين والمدنيين
النقاشات حول الصياغات الفنيه والعامه
النهائيه للتوصيات التفصيليه لورشه العمل
بغيت نشرها للراي العام وادراجها في مسوده
الاتفاق السياسي الجلسه التي انعقدت بغياب
الاطراف الاساسيه وهما الجيش والدعم
السريع اكدت ان الخلافه بينهما اكبر من
نقاط الاتفاق ورشه الاصلاح الامني اختتمت
اعمالها بلا توصيات الامر الذي يعقد
بالوصول لاتفاق النهائي سالم الهاشمي
العربي الخرطوم
نشد مدير الوكاله الدوليه للطاقه الذريره
وموسكو الاتفاق على مبادئ تفضل ضمان
سلامتي محطه
في اوكرانيا اوضح في تصريحات ادلى بها بعد
زيارته الثانيه لمحطه منذ بدء الازمه
الروسيه الاوكرانيه انه يسعى الاقتراح حل
وسط بين طرفين لتجنب كارثه نوويه وحضر
روسي بعد زيارته الثانيه للمحطه من ان
الوضع العام في المحطه لا يتحسن وذلك
بالتسامن مع تصاعد النشاط العسكري
قال رئيس هيئه الاركان الامريكيه الجنرال
مارت ميلان القدرات النوويه الصينيه لا
تضاهي قدرات الولايات المتحده لكن واشنطن
تواجه قوتين عظمين مسلحتين نوويا هما
بيكين وموسكو
القدرات النوويه الصينيه لا تضاهي قدرات
الولايات المتحده لكن عندما تبدا الحديث
عن الاسلحه النوويه فهي هائله لذلك عليك
ان تسال ما مقدار الشيء المماثل لديهم
قدره نوويه كبيره اليوم دون الخوض في
ارقام محدده لديهم صواريخ باليستيه عابره
للقارات يمكن ان تصل الى الولايات المتحده
وهو امر مزعج بشكل واضح لذلك نحن الان
نواجه قوتين عضميين مسلحتين نوويا لا تزال
مبادئ الردع للحرب البارده ساريه لكنها
الان اكثر تعقيدا لانها اثنان مقابل واحد
وفي اي وقت تكون لديك ثلاثه متغيرات مقابل
متغير واحد او اثنين يكون الوضع اكثر
تعقيدا
كشف احدث تقرير حول الاسلحه النوويه عن
زياده ترسانه النوويه العالميه بعشرات
الرؤوس الجاهزه للاستخدام من قبل الجيوش
حيث بلغ سباقه تسلح النووي اعلى مستوياته
منذ الحرب البارده
[موسيقى]
بمقدار 135 الف ضعف من هذا الانفجار يبلغ
حجم ترسانه العالم النوويه ترسانه اخذه
بالازدياد مع زياده التوتر بين اقطابها
ففي احدث تقرير لمرصد حظر الاسلحه النوويه
ومقره النرويج فان المخزون النووي مطلع
العام الحالي زاد بمقدار 136 راسا نوويا
ليبلغ
12,512 راسا نوويا منها
2936 راسا احيلت الى التفكيك في حين ان
9576 راسا متاحه للاستخدام من قبل الجيوش
قوتها التدميريه مجتمعه تزيد عن 135 الف
مره من قنبلته هيروشيما
السباق هو وفقا للمرصد بلغ اعلى مستوياته
منذ الحرب البارده حيث تاتي زياده في
السنه الاخيره جراء مواصله دول خمس توسيع
مخزونها النووي وهي الصين روسيا كوريا
الشماليه وباكستان والهند ومنذ التاسع
والعشرين من مارس الحالي بلغ عدد الدول
الاطراف معاهده حظر الاسلحه النوويه 68
دوله وقعت 27 دوله اخرى على المعاهده
لكنها لم تصدق عليها بعد وهذا يعني ان 4
دول فقط تحتاج الى التوقيع او الانضمام
قبل ان تصل المعاهده الى 50% من جميع
الدول
مقلقه زياده بينما كان الوضع عليه قبل حرب
اوكرانيا وما بعدها يقول محرر مرصد حظر
الاسلحه النوويه غريت اوسترن سباق ان لم
يتوقف فسنشهد زياده في العدد الاجمالي
للاسلحه النوويه لم نشهده منذ الحرب
البارده وربما اسوا
نشرتنا مستمره وتتابعون فيها بعض الفاصل
رئيس الامارات يعين منصور بن سعيد نائبا
للرئيس الى الجانب محمد بن راشد وخالد بن
محمد بن زايد وليا للعهد في ابوظبي
اهلا بكم من جديد اصدر رئيس دوله الامارات
الشيخ محمد بن زايد قرارا بتعيين الشيخ
منصور بن زايد نائبا لرئيس الدوله الى
جانب الشيخ محمد بن راشد واقرر الشيخ محمد
بن زايد تعيين الشيخ خالد بن محمد بن زايد
وليا للعهد في اماره ابو ظبي كما اصدر
الشيخ محمد بن زايد قرارا بتعيينه الشيخ
هزاع بن زايد والشيخ طحنون بن زايد نائبين
لحاكم ابو ظبي
عبرت الدول مجموعه العشرين عن قلقها تجاه
النشاط الاستخباراتي الصيني بعد ان تبين
انبيكين ترسل عملائها لملاحقه منتصفهم
بالفاسدين
رجل عمل صيني يقبع وراء القضبان في
الولايات المتحده بتهمه اختلاس مليار
دولار ليست هذه تهمه الفساد الاولى التي
يواجهها وانجواي فقد استقر في امريكا منذ
عشر سنوات بعد ان وجهت له تهم فساد في
الصين التي تلاحقه كما تلاحق غيره ممن
تصفهم بالفاسدين لدى بكين برنامج تديره
هيئه محاربه الفساد تحت اسم فوكس هاند اي
صيد الثعالب عدد من الدول الغربيه قليقه
من هذا الامر حيث تشك بان الصين تتخذ من
ملاحقه الفاسدين ذريعه لاجراء عمليه
استخباراتيه عبر ارسال عملائها للعمل في
سفاراتها في امريكا وغيرها من الدول تحت
غطاء انهم ملحقون دبلوماسيون قانونيون
لكن الروايه الرسميه الصينيه تقول ان
الهدف هو القبض على الفاسدين الهاربين
واعاده ما نهبوه من اموال في اطار التعاون
الدولي وتقول بكين انها نجحت من خلال
برنامج
ان تلقي القبض على عشره الاف وسبعمائه
متهم بالفساد وان تسترد ما يفوق خمسه
مليارات دولار
المحكمه الاوروبيه لحقوق الانسان اوقفت في
2022 ترحيل رجل تايواني تتهمه الصين
بالفساد في مجال الاتصالات مخافه ان يتعرض
للتعذيب الامر الذي يطرح تساؤلات عده حول
امكانيه استخدام بكين لبرامجها التي تقول
انها لمحاربه الفساد للقبض على المعارضين
لها في الخارج
انسنا ماسي العربيه
تعاني الاف الاسر اليمنيه في مدينه تعز من
شح المياه نتيجه نضوب مياه الابار وتدميري
مشروع المياه الحكوميه وشبكته الداخليه
باسلحه الحوثيين سكان المدينه يلجاون الى
جلب مياه الشرب من مصادر اخرى خارج
المدينه ما يكلفهم مبالغ ماليه كبيره
بالاضافه الى تعرض العديد من الاطفال
للمخاطر اثناء جلب المياه
لساعات طويله تحت الشمس وفي نهار رمضان
يصطف هؤلاء الاطفال كل يوم للحصول على
حاجتهم من مياه الشرب اذ يعتمدون كليا على
ما يحضره لهم هذا الصهريج من مياه والبعض
منهم قد لا يعود الى منزله باكثر من
ثلاثين لترا من المياه تمكنه واسرته من
التغلب على العطش الناس يعانوا من صحه
المياه ولذلك يساربوا على الماء من وحد
الظهر احيانا الى اربع واحيانا الى ست
واحيانا ولا يجدوه الماء فكل يوم نفس
المعنى هذه
اصلا ما فيش معنا ما والوقت غالي ما في
الا فاعل الخير هنا ونتجمع من الساعه 2:00
بين الشمس هؤلاء يبدون في احسن حال ممن لا
تصلهم اياه السبيل في بقيه الاحياء فالالف
من المواطنين في المدينه يلجاون لشراء
المياه بمبالغ باهضه فيما البعض الاخرين
يلجاون لجلب حاجتهم من المياه من خزانات
المساجد لاسيما مع نضوب عشرات الابار
الارتوازيه وتتحكم الميليشيات الحوثيه
بالاحواض المائيه في مناطق سيطرتها بمنطقه
الحيمه شرقي تعز المصادر الرئيسيه للمياه
اساسا موجوده تحت سيطرات الانقلابيه في
الحوبان وهي ترفض حتى اليوم رغم وجود بعض
لجان الوساطه المحليه وايضا الدوليه من
الضخم الى خزانه المؤسسه حتى يشرب الناس
مدينه تعز على 88 بئران جوفيان موزعه على
عدد من الحقول هي حقوق الرئيسيه الثلاثه
المتواجد في منطقه الضباب ومنطقه الحوله
ومنطقه الحمى
كل هذه الحقول المتوقفه تماما منذ بدء
الحرب اكثر من مليونين نسمه في المدينه
يتهددهم العطش بعد ان دمرت الميليشيات
الحوثيه مؤسسه المياه وشبكتي الضخ
والامداد تدميرا ممنهجا كلف قطاع المياه
في تعز خسائر بملايين الدولارات وفاقم من
معاناه السكان في المدينه
هائل سعيد العربيه تعز
يحاول السوريون اعاده الحياه الى المناطق
التي ضربها الزلزال مدمر في شمال سوريا
حيث عاده الاسواق الشعبيه للعمل على الرغم
من الصعوبات التي يعيشها السوريون ويعد
ارتفاع الاسعار وانعدام القدره الشرائيه
لديهم من ابرز الصعوبات التي يواجهونها
خصوصا في المناطق التي ضربها الزلزال
عادت اصوات البائعين الى ناحيه جنديرس
المنكوبه لتملا احيائها المدمره بضجيج
الاسواق الشعبيه التي اعتاد الاهالي على
زيارتها لشراء البضائع بسعر اقل من تلك
التي تعرض في المحال التجاريه خصوصا ان
اغلب اهالي المنطقه عانوا من كارثه
الزلزال المدمر الذي اثر سلبا على القدره
الشرائيه لديهم بعد زلزال وضع تعبان السوق
كان قبل كويس هون سوق شعبي يعني قبل كان
كويس ماشي الحال تيجي العالم وتروح هلا ما
في حدا يعني طلعت بره يعني انا جاي ادرس
بدي ابسط بدي اشتغل بدي استمر بالحياه
الحياه الحياه
اسمها يصير ما راح توقف الحياه مستمره
يشكو الاهالي هنا من ارتفاع الاسعار مما
دفع اغلبهم للاكتفاء بشراء المواد
الغذائيه الاساسيه وتجاهل اصوات بائعي
باقي البضائع ويعزو الاهالي ذلك بسبب
الكارثه التي حلت بهم والاضرار التي لحقت
بممتلكاتهم ما في قدره شرائيه غير على
الخضره كما العام عم تشتغل وتشتري خضره
تماما فقط لا غير بالنسبه للالبسه والباله
والجديد شغله ضعيف ما في ما في عندنا
الناس قدره ما في عندها قدره شرائيه يعني
عايشه اول باول اغراض غاليه وين بدي اجيب
وين بدي اجيب
في رحمه الله عنا يحاول السوريون العوده
للحياه رغم ضعف الامكانيات خصوصا بعد
كارثه الزلزال الذي تسبب بفقدان الكثير من
الاهالي لممتلكاتهم واعمالهم مما ادى
لتراجع الحركه الاقت صاديه في عموم
المنطقه احيت اصوات الباعه وضجيج
المتسوقين الامل في المناطق التي ضربها
الزلزال في شمال غرب سوريا
ليشوبها ارتفاع الاسعار وعدم قدره الاهالي
على شراء كافه احتياجاتهم خصوصا ان اغلبهم
فقد منزله وعمله وبات يعيش في خيمه قماشيه
محمد الاشقر العربيه شمال سوريا
اكدت وزاره الخارجيه الامريكيه ان اسرائيل
لم تفي بعد بالمتطلبات التي تؤهلها
للانضمام الى برنامج الاعفاء من التاشيرات
الامريكيه والتي من اهمها السماح للاشخاص
الذين يحملون الجنسيتين الفلسطينيه
والامريكيه العبور بحريه والدخول الى
الضفه الغربيه من جهته اعلن رئيس الوزراء
الاسرائيلي في وقت سابق انه يتوقع انضمام
بلاده قريبا للبرنامج
افادت وكاله رويترز للانباء بان هيئه
المحلفين الخاصه بقضيه الرئيس الامريكي
السابق دونالد ترامب لن تحقق بالقضيه قبل
اجازه عيد الفصح والذي سيكون في شهر ابريل
المقبل وذلك كما يؤخر توجيه اي اتهامات
محتمله ضد الرئيس الامريكي الاسبق
دع الملياردير الامريكي له ماسكو ومجموعه
من خبراء الذكاء الاصطناعي الى التوقفي
لمده سته اشهر عن تطوير انظمه اقوى من
روبوت الدردشه
اربعه الذي اطلقته شركه اوبن في الاونه
الاخيره محذرين من المخاطر المحتمله لمثل
هذه التطبيقات على المجتمع وقالت الرساله
الصادره عن معهد فيوتشر اوف لايف انه يجب
تطوير انظمه الذكاء الاصطناعي القويه فقط
عند التاكد من ان اثارها ستكون ايجابيه
وان مخاطرها ستكون تحت السيطره
انتهت يوم امس المهله التي اعطاها البيت
الابيض لموظفين الوكالات الفيدراليه
الامريكيه لازاله التطبيق الصيني تيك توك
من الاجهزه الحكوميه وبررت الاداره
الامريكيه القرار بمخاوف تتعلق بالامان
والخصوصيه بشان الروابط المزعومه لتطبيق
وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي مع الحكومه
الصينيه
مع انتهاء المهله المعطاه للموظفين
الحكوميين الامريكيين لحجب تيك توك من
هواتفهم يعود التركيز على المخاطر الامنيه
التي يشكلها التطبيق الصيني الاشهر فعلى
الرغم من الحرب في اوكرانيا احتلت الصين
معظم المناقشات عندما اطلع رؤساء وكاله
الاستخبارات البلاد المشرعين على
التهديدات الرئيسيه للولايات المتحده
النقاش تركز بالطبع على نقاط الضعف غير
العسكريه للولايات المتحده تجاه الصين فما
هي نقاط الضعف هذه يجيبنا رئيس تحرير قسم
التكنولوجيا والعلوم في موقع ديسنس
بالتاكيد يمكننا القاء نظره على بعض
الامثله لسرقه الملكيه الفكريه واعاده
استخدامها الصين سرقت الملكيه الفكريه
للمسيرات العسكريه الامريكيه وصنعت مسيره
لها مما جعل الولايات المتحده تضطر الى
اعاده تصميم جوانب جديده في هذا البرنامج
الولايات المتحده تخسر مليارات الدولارات
في الملكيه الفكريه العسكريه وفي القطاع
الخاص ايضا
يقول ان التيك توك يهدد امن وخصوصيه
الامريكيين مضيفا ان الحزب الشيوعي الصيني
قد يخترق هواتف الامريكيين باستخدام
التطبيق الامر الذي يحتم وضع ضوابط للتاكد
من عدم تحوله الى اداه تجسس تهدد امن
وخصوصيه الامريكيين
بحذف الموظفين الحكوميين لتطبيق تيك توك
على هواتفهم يبقى الامل بوقف تسريب
البيانات الحاليه هناك الكثير من
المعلومات التي يمكن لتطبيق تيك توك ان
يستخرجها من الهاتف وبعض رجال الاستخبارات
يعتبر انه من الافضل التخلص من الهواتف
التي كان عليها التطبيق وليس فقط التخلص
وحذف
التطبيقات من الصين لكن التحدي الهائل
يكمن في اقناع الامريكيين بالتهديد الذي
يشكله تيك توك خاصه وان بعض المجموعات
التي تدعم حريه التعبير والحريات المدنيه
تعارض هذه الخطوه مستشهده بالتعديل الاول
العربيه واشنطن
ازمه الطفل شنوده اثارت الراي العام في
مصر على مدى عام بعد فصله عن اسرته التي
تبنته وربته بعد ان عثرت عليه منذ خمس
سنوات في احدى الكنائس نظرا للصراع الذي
حدث حول ديانه الطفل قبل ان يحسم الازهر
الجدل بتبعيه الطفل للديانه المسيحيه
واعادته لوالديه بالتبني رنده ابو العزم
رافقت الاسره اثناء اجراءات تسلم ابنها
ورصدت لحظات الفرحه
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
نهايه سعيده وبدايه لحياه سعيده للطفل
شنوده الذي عاد اخيرا الى حضن اسرته
بالتبني امال وفاروق بعد رحله معاناه
للطفل والاسره امتدت لاكثر من عام
قولي لي بقى لما شوفتي شنوده النهارده
عملت ايه طبعا حضنته وبصته وهو باسني
وحضني وقال لي يا ماما كفايه دي بالدنيا
كلها تفتكري مدام امال ان هو هيحتاج اي حد
نفسي يقعد معه يريحه بصي اكيد اكيد بس انا
يعني
الكنيسه وكده
وربنا يتدخل بقى ربنا يكمل كان نفسك تشوفي
شنوده فين بيشتغل ايه عايزه شايفه مستقبل
في مخه انه يطلع دكتور كان كل ما حد يساله
يقول له انا اسمي الدكتور شنوده فاروق
وفوزي بولس غبريال اكبر جراح في مصر
العالمي شنوده الذي عثر عليه عام 2018 في
احدى الكنائس تبنته السيده امال وزوجها
وبعد اربع سنوات تقدمت احدى قريبات الوالد
بسبب خلافات حول الميراث ببلاغ كيدي بان
الطفل مختطف ولم يعثر عليه في الكنيسه
الامر الذي ادى الى ايد اعه منذ عام في
احدى دور الرعايه ودخول الاسره في اجراءات
قانونيه وقضائيه انتهت بصدور فتاوى من
الازهر ودار الافتاء بان الطفل يتبع ديانه
الاسره المسيحيه التي وجدته في الكنيسه
وصدور قرار من النيابه بتسليم الطفل
لاسرته بالتبني الطفل ده عدل تشريعات لم
تستطع مؤسسات كبيره في مصر ان تعدلها هذا
الطفل لم تكن قانون الاسره بديله يطبق على
المسيحيين كلمه اسره مؤقته اثار
لان
المفروض اني ان الاسره تنهي اجراءات
الاسره البديله كل هذه الامور قد تستغرق
شهر او شهرين فكانت النيابه العظيمه
المحترمه النيابه العامه يعني لديها من حس
الانساني والحس القانوني وبعد الانساني
قالت لا يعني احنا دلوقتي يقعدوا شهر على
الطفل بعيد عن ابوه امه والقرار صادر
فاحنا هندي مصطفى مؤقته وهي بعد كده تجيب
الحاجات دي كلها وبحسب القانون فان قرار
النيابه اسدل الستار على ماساه طفل لم
يتعدى الخمس سنوات ليعود الى حضن الام
والاب بالتبني والذي لم يعرف غيرهما راندا
ابو العزم العربيه القاهره
في نهايه نشا هذا تذكير بابرازيه عناوينه
اصابه عسكريين سوريين في هجوم اسرائيلي
استهدف محيط العاصمه السوريه دمشق
في السودان الحريه والتغيير تحسم موقفها
اليوم من هيكله السلطه والجيش يؤكد
التزامه بالعمليه السياسيه
وخبراء يؤكدون او يطالبون بوقف تطوير
انظمه الذكاء الاصطناعي مؤقتا بسبب خطرها
على المجتمع
الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]